oh Jesus whoo
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's a show of hot
questions even hotter wings today I'm
joined by the best-looking fat guy in
the universe
Charlie sloth Buddha you can catch him I
BBC one Radio BBC 1xtra is the hardest
work in DJ and Great Britain he's got
the hottest hip hop show in the UK
that's what Europe is all of us at ye
olde your map I'm I am Buddhist ye
jewelry and today we're gonna eat some
scorching hot chicken wings Charlie
welcome to the show I'm nervous bro you
are yeah a little bit
how are you with hot food I'm good with
what foods I love spice in my life spicy
teens is good but I've seen the show a
lot and I've seen the reaction that
certain people get and I'm just laughing
there what are you ready to get it going
already student we're all starving
[Music]
Charlie going that's good mom
ladies means room where these wings from
Red Dog so I want to start by talking
about firing the booth using such a
great way for a lot of these MCS to kind
of set a bar within the first month or
doing find a booth like I'd said to the
bosses it hit a million views and the
first artists to do that was Kay Koch
and off the back of that he got signed
by rock nation jay-z came over signed
the paperwork with him there was this
massive Asteria rank a cold and he's
firing a booth in particular and from
there I understood I truly understood
the power of that platform and what we
presented to British culture does
anybody freestyle any more 9m days a
good does it matter
nah you know when I'm doing just like
old you know freestyle just come on man
time to change anything is delivering
your best that's what I care about that
you give a hundred percent to live your
best but if I think a noise can do
better than what they've delivered let's
take two let's go again bro always way
if you tossing will be ruined just start
tucking in I'm starving I eat is going
to go question in time sometimes it's
kind of layered now you're seeing you
know we're pulling back the curtain now
Charlie so since I've been in London
I've had a chance to hang out with a lot
of British youth and I got to be real
with you I mean having trouble keeping
up with the local lingo I'm hoping I can
do it just bounce some of the common
words and phrases are we doing and you
can maybe times I Jean use them in a
sentence yeah yeah I need all the help I
can get
waste man waste man waste man so someone
says you're a waste man it means you're
pretty worthless
it means like they don't they don't
think very highly of you chirps chirps a
bird yes so chirps a bird it's like shut
up
so if you see a hot spice you know hot
spices oh girl that's hot yeah like you
would say yo going chops that go or I'm
gonna go and chirps that girl which
means I'm gonna gonna chat that girl up
because she kind of spicy can we talk
about pang because I've heard storms you
say that it means attractive I was
hanging out with the chicken connoisseur
earlier I mean since Sophie is ping yeah
so what the hell he's talking yeah so
pain basically means exquisite ping this
map it's that moves me when I was
heating that we nailed laughs mmm that
was a pain wing so if you see something
that's hot again
she's a painting or if you have some
food and it means good good so I want to
talk about crime in the UK rap scene for
a second you know you have artists like
storm Z and Skepta who bubble up but I
think for more casual hip-hop fans
stateside some of them maybe haven't
heard those names yet as talented as
those artists are as somebody who is
intimately involved with the scene on
both sides of the pond what do you think
are the biggest differences I don't
think that difference is not great
anymore I really don't I think the last
time I said you know it's pretty much it
one's power level I think the main thing
still is the language barrier I'm not
gonna ask you which is better to pick a
side but I would like to know if you
think that there's something on this
side of the pond where there's a little
bit of an advantage to the art is there
some maybe one ah you know I do you know
what I you know what I think over here
right now it feels like everything is
very fresh
I feel like British music has his own
identity and his own sound which we
never had for a long time American hip
hop rap I started to feel a little
recycled and I love it that list even
the new stuff I'm a fan but it feels
like there's nothing new about what's
being done that's good sauce I want to
unpack into this honey gene thing know
that I get these characters kind of pop
up in the United States every once in a
while too you'll see like slim Jesus
flare up or on the other side of the
spectrum even somebody like Matty V and
it gets harder and harder every day it
seems too personal what authenticity
even is in hip-hop anymore that's a good
question
because even you know if honey G was as
corny as she was in terms of musically
as long as she was being herself I
wouldn't
okay now obviously understand mrs.
entertainment sound sighs people
glamorize things and you know there
might spice things up but at the end of
the day when the curtain comes down you
need to ask yourself was you the
best.you that's the difference between
wolf being authentic or being a
commodity or parity we're gonna talk
about mu k little T soft ass and how do
you think about those characters that
way what are your thoughts on them it's
interesting because you know a lot of
people hit me up and then I this guy is
easy to find a proof there God look at
their views and when I'm looking for a
nice find a booth no look at the views
right I'm listening I'm not looking what
the numbers are but numbers can be
manipulated and people can lack things
for the wrong reason so I'm never gonna
gravitate towards views for me it's all
about the music the music the bars
that's it a lot of people up as far as
Blackpool were getting involved and
creating a scene up there but it's not
something that I'm gonna be excited by I
am excited for this you are yeah I'm
gonna give you my opinion that's great
that's great that's good you get a
sweetness but mm-hmm
they hit you British bad that's good
well let me suck up to you for a second
cuz as we already said uh-huh you're the
best-looking fat guy universe in the
[ __ ] universe why would I do you have
any style or grooming tips for the husky
gentleman watching us right now cuz my
guess is there are a fair number of them
now I'm not concerned about how I look
would I take one more photo that got me
who I know where about gold girls if
we're over me and you know why that is
I believe in myself there I believe that
I'm beautiful if you don't believe that
you're beautiful no one else gonna
believe that you like it are your cute
little rebel chic oh you're so cute that
that like I'm beautiful babe I'm not
cute I'm beautiful look at me
oh my eyes stunning don't feel right
because you're fighting on worse on me -
what skinny jeans on cuz manse
mantle beasts I'm morbidly obese but
don't be afraid man embrace the fatness
all right and then I just have one more
question for you why'd the jacket in the
studio all the time is it cold in the
studio why is there always a gentleman
charlie so it's a good question so no
one's ever asked me this question that
is a great question bro for me I'm very
superstitious and there was one time in
the studio
God didn't wear my jacket and the show
was terrible it was really bad like
there was a lot of swearing that went on
in the show I missed a lot of segues I
missed the news twice so it was a bad
day and I I left the building that day
thinking wow how is this show so bad I'm
so on point didn't every jacket what
Jackie would name and from that day on
I've never sat down and done my show
without my jacket so that's the stew as
a true story is grow and they warn
everybody knows that everyone the
buildings always not well now the world
knows yeah there you go
[Music]
just cool it
Ewan McGregor anymore say that you will
see that yeah you like a young you
McGregor I'll take the money was in
trades when I took company it's a high
compliment yeah thank you I'm wishing
you already associate face to face hey
Santa geez but with a with a win the
zone so you're highly versed in the cost
of ambition yeah and when I read your
interviews the things that stick out to
me the most and maybe because they
resonate with with me the most is when
you talk about how you need to worry
about the growth and the success of your
wave of your scene yeah and not your
personal comfort and not your paycheck I
was touching in the earlier about people
chasing things for financial gain rather
them because their passion where they
believe in it and that you just sit
there that's where people [ __ ] off it's
when it goes wrong I didn't get into
this because of money
I didn't start listening to rap and
grime because I wanted to make money I
listened to it because I was passionate
about it and then the more I've got
engrossed in the scene the more I cared
about not only the culture were the
people in the culture like that's the
bottom line I think in all aspects of
business
understand your audience kaor you
audience
[Music]
this is very light yeah Charlie I think
if that one don't win it no you did it
that's see that hot sauce I feel like it
hurt you I'm gonna do wait I've never
lost weight while I'm eating
that's why wow you're one of the most
influential DJs and Europe and as
somebody with that kind of pedigree I'm
sure that you get SoundCloud links all
the do it
yeah mixtapes by the truckload how do
you stand out outside of just listen to
my mixtape ur tweeting a SoundCloud play
you know what it's cool I want to start
repeating myself a little bit but this
one is very simple there's a great
woofer the purple car you like that but
I won't go Charlie so it's a picture
this way if you driving past a field on
the way home every day move to a new
house first thing you driving past that
field you're gonna see a fuel then it's
not 30 cows name stopping uh-oh
it's funny cuz in that field second day
you drive past is tough 20 cars they 50
you drive bus you're not even looking
because you know what's there there's 50
cows you know it if one day you're
driving home from work and there's a
purple cow in that field you slam on
your [ __ ] brace as a purple cow it's
something that is standing out for you
every day and it's the same as a nice
man
dismiss you with the younger artists the
next generation they feel like they have
to conform to dress a certain way speak
a certain way for them to fit in but if
you just want to fit in that's all you
want to do so this one is the barbie is
an addiction a lot of a man that's good
I'm not preaching that word
it's another hot one Jesus whoo Wow
imagine where I wasn't that I know take
off a little bit
one of my favorite projects that you did
is it's crime up north
okay I know that you're big on finding
guys that no one else is discovered one
knows he's wandering that's good that's
raisi
but I want to relate that now to food if
you were to do that project over again
and instead of looking with the wrappers
that no one has found yet
and instead you're looking for the
regional dishes that you love the most
which ones would you feature
oh that's a great one I can hardly speak
right now that's the show I am in pain
this is great now so me crazy as a
crazier than you thought yeah yeah yeah
I'm sweating my mouth baby knows he's
running this is a lot so if I could
travel up north and show some food I'll
go to York shop for great traditional
British roast I'll go to Liverpool get
some gravy and chips I kind of a talker
this is wild how you're talking what am
I gonna do it is Sahira silent man was
much much more easy
um and then pour Igor to Scotland
Scotland there's some haggis no I've had
this before I don't have it don't is
this costume bias one
so this is mad dog 357 it is bad how
hard is this one to this uh this one to
me is the toughest one on this line of
yeah well what is 50 min this is by the
book if you're gonna go by the Scoville
scale the hottest one but this to me
it's just like a barb you know what I
mean it's just something about it it's a
little busiest one that you say is semi
a person hotter than a jalapeno it's
it's something like that it's crazy and
it might even be more than that I think
it's like 86 are you serious let me see
you let me see you make sure you got
sauce on that one you can see you make a
noise switch now I've got you bro I've
got faith in you I'm waiting I just let
it take down
Oh
take a lap Charlie take a lap Charlie
it's not the first lap we've seen here
whoa little red in the face careful
around your eyes whoa you even lasted
overall I'm impressed mine you go ahead
bro that is wild
so you're the vape God I see in the club
VIP always blowing the biggest smoke
sense but as a VIP guy myself I
sometimes wonder you know I'm kind of
caught is is vaping cool or is it not
cool it's a lot cooler than smoking
cigarettes now over here you do smoking
a cigarette and 27 people looking at my
my smoking a cigarette hey stink you
know ain't no way trying to stink is
2017 it's like you're killing yourself
really quickly you're spending a lot of
money and you stink there's no winning
do you get all into the flavors cuz I
get kind of into him I'm like I'm crazy
I'll try the fruity pebbles I'm all into
it well my tour manager is there he'll
tell you every city we go to we got into
the vape show like no matter where I am
in the world I'm granting the picture
I'm gonna find it I know she's running
bro all right Charlie well Matt's that
time it's that time it's tradition
around here to put a little extra dab on
the last one it's gonna gloss you of you
don't have to if you don't want to need
one you love wait here it is there it is
there it is and before you take the bike
okay I have to sign of contracts no no
no I think I think I already did
actually okay you're one of the most
hyped DJs in the game you're the
catchphrase King and so what I want to
do on this last wing is have a drop off
okay I'll hit you with the drop and then
you hit me with the drop and then the
first one to drop the ball loses okay
you can go with your sound board I'm
gonna go with famous quotes and that's
not that's not fair no easy was you got
so many cheese from yoga and food a
have that many filed up I don't have
that many drops let's just go ahead
let's go he's the light the wing and
I'll start I'll start does that sound
good yeah all right cheers charlyk
cheers bro you went in with a and my
foot
Tinashe where you add your voice are
these two off the peoples prints the
best ugly fat guy in the universe the
man with a plan if I can't do it to your
mom I'll do a team when you're none it's
got some Wang to it
chi boy try to stuff the people spread
the best of the bad guy in the universe
if I think Jamal ready this all new
gender oh [ __ ]
we are here ain't we oh [ __ ] my nuts is
sweating where's that from Coolio oh my
God my mouse is suede no I'm your
[ __ ] not my mouth is doing backflips
is that a drop I feel like it counts
yeah that's not into the mix good cool
man and then you put the hinges in the
fuckboys hands
Connie go Souter that was great you know
my mouth is doing so much my brain ain't
working right so this is a good game I
see why you've done this um she which is
not the people's print the basically fat
guy in the universe either way there's
but looking at me
that camera that camera
let the people know what you have going
on in here oh my goodness so much going
on right now of course you catch me
Monday to Friday BBC made your one extra
for the 7:00 p.m. you can this all
online even not from the UK but you need
you K you know what to do every Saturday
night when it's your and radio one the
biggest rap show in the world
men lie women line numbers don't have
mom men's or complex so I think we'll
just take one quick pic and then hey
what's going on hot ones fans if you
like the video maybe meet us halfway
throw us a subscribe if you didn't like
the video don't subscribe I don't want
you I don't want you in the tent but if
you liked the video subscribe thank you
very much
I appreciate you I love you more than a
friend